[Music]
good morning everyone it's a pleasure to
have you here
my name is innocent vid I'm product
manager in cloud networking working in
many things among others DK on Prem part
of our Antos announcement and lounge in
this in this next one I'm gonna have the
pleasure of having with me
Satya who's the lead engineer for DK on
Prem networking and Poland Scott who
we've been working very closely on the
DK on Prem in the last in the last month
and you know I'll go really quick
because who wants to listen to a product
manager when you got the real people so
let's talk a little bit about how we're
seeing the DK evolution what it means to
our offering and why it is such an
important piece of what we do in Google
Cloud so you are very familiar with
containers you know that you know we've
been working on the industry and open
source has been working on container
racing applications and that allows us
to attract the infrastructure resources
and kubernetes really has become in that
journey the de facto Orchestrator for
the container race applications so it
has many advantages it allows to
modernize applications it provides the
portability so that you can actually
develop your applications and then you
can port and deploy very fundamental on
how we as Google see the public cloud
and you know our view that it should be
multi-cloud it should be open it should
be portable so why
kubernetes has been so successful so it
really provides the capabilities of not
only Yorkist rate in your applications
at your workloads but it provides
certain properties that make it very
appealing so you have stable IP for your
services you you're able to deploy your
applications within the cluster and then
provide a stable IP and stable
communication to the external world but
internally the pod eyepiece and the pods
that are used for serving that
application are ephemeral so that gives
you the flexibility while serving the
applications to the external world it is
stable now it provides you as well with
the flexibility of delivering layer for
services delivering ingress services
through a layer seven capabilities we
[Music]
the implementation of kubernetes have
been delivering Polly pieces first-class
citizens so that they are routable to
the pods now as part of your deployments
as well do you have the capability of
having policies and then you're able to
declare that certain applications are
able to communicate with others and that
are those are network policies as well
standardized API is that you can use for
declaring your intentions of
communication your of communicating your
your applications and then you can do so
as well within the clusters and the in
certain have certain applications that
are exposed to the external world some
others that are only made available
internally and only through the paths
and they from the applications that are
meaningful to that communication so now
we as Google Cloud have been delivering
solutions for kubernetes kubernetes has
been again
changer for developers it really
provides the de-facto way of modernizing
applications now obviously it's been
very successful
for developers because all these
flexibility and portability that it
provides now the issue is when you are
delivering these applications and you
are doing it for production environments
you still have the day to operations to
care about so you need to care about
managing the components you need to care
about upgrading the nodes on the cluster
you need to care about auto scaling
providing high availability auto repairs
and therefore we felt that part of the
problem statement has not really been
solved with kubernetes so now what we
have been working really hard in the
last few years is delivering you know
the solution for the second part of the
problem now we want to deliver a
solution that is providing the
manageability of the cluster with
upgrades with outer repairs with auto
scaling and that is really the beauty of
DKA it is really the solution not only
for your developers but also for the
system platform operators so it really
takes the yearning of kubernetes from a
developer tool to an enterprise ready
solution to be deployed for your
production environments now as you can
see you know we've been delivering
solutions for high availability so then
you can have SAS as part of your
deployments for example we've been
providing high availability not only for
the cluster but also for the master
is regional master so that you can have
availability in data plane in control
plane we provide auto patching you know
for example taking care of vulnerability
security vulnerability issues we provide
auto repair we provide auto scaling we
provide for example solutions for
managed TLS certificates so you can
think of it of a complete end-to-end
enterprise ready solution and we really
see this as fundamental platform for us
to deliver the capabilities of our cloud
to our customers so the growth of DK in
Google cloud has been enormous and we'll
just see more and more enterprises
really taking advantage of the ideality
of containers combined with the
manageability of the platform itself and
the security capabilities the automatics
capabilities that the platform provides
but you know the journey does not end
there
we've been very busy adding more value
what is that value as we are delivering
the DK as the game changer for the
platform operator we are doing so not
only on our platform but also for your
on-prem environment it's been really
something that many enterprises have
been asking us to do they want to see
the capabilities of DK the manageability
the readiness the security not only for
the cloud environments but also for the
romper umbrellas and you know we're
going to have Scott and Paul talking
about why that is important and
there are many reasons why you know
enterprises might not be able to deploy
certain applications in the cloud but
what we are doing is providing the same
principles that we have in our cloud in
on-prem so what does that mean we mean
that we are able to provide clusters
that are able to be group unable to be
controlled and managed there is an
administration cluster there are control
plane that runs on Prem so that you
actually have a standalone operating
cluster on Prem whether there is
connectivity or not to cloud but it gets
automatically started up it has
connectivity with the registry that runs
as well locally so that starts up and
then it gets registered in the cloud so
that we have the credentials we have the
security and a single pane of glass for
visibility it shows in our cloud console
and then you're able to really manage
the functions of your cluster as you
will do if it is in decay in DCP now it
is important again to know that we
understand that the deployment needs to
be operating in on prime so we've been
very careful of offering the
capabilities of running autonomously in
on Prem even though it has a register to
the cloud for manageability reasons so
that we can do up to upgrade we can
actually manage the cluster and you know
the boring part is over
so more interesting I want to welcome on
States paul paul Ravello is in HSBC is
being a very trusted partner in all the
journey and he's going to talk more
about why this is important for their
deployments in HSBC
welcome Paul HSBC Oh No yeah hey guys my
name is Paul I work at HSBC an
enterprise cloud architect there my team
is responsible for helping to set the
cloud strategy at the bank typically
that means public cloud for us but we
are now building out internal cloud
capabilities as well and we've settled
on kubernetes to help us achieve that a
little bit about HSBC we're a very large
organization we're spread out globally a
large number of IT professionals and we
have all of the challenges that that
typically brings in large enterprises
when it comes to infrastructure
provisioning application development
application deployment patch management
so you know when we started looking at
this stuff we we really had a list of
items that kind of have a long lead time
typically at the bank and we really
wanted to fix them so if you look at a
standard application deployment in our
enterprise its VM based VM based
applications require VMs to be deployed
we have a Niyaz capability on premise
but it's not necessarily a rapid
provisioning it still has a lead time
associated with it it's a very static
type of provisioning you ask for
something you get that something there's
no real leeway there if you need
something else you have to ask for
something else later on down the road
moving to kubernetes and GK on Prem we
can have pre-built infrastructure that
supports the kubernetes environment and
then we can give people the ability to
create images that they can deploy there
and not have to wait for infrastructure
to be provisioned to do that that's a
very big win for us
it gives us the ability to really
rapidly change the posture there
IP allocation is a problem that we
normally have on-premise when it comes
to infrastructure provisioning the
reason that's an issue for us is it's a
little bit of a manual process but it's
also a static thing right
IPS are tied to many things in a typical
VM application deployment they're tied
to DNS names they're tied to maybe
licensing whatever it might be right
there's a there's a one-to-one mapping
there of something usually when we go to
kubernetes and we're running in island
mode with gke on-premise specifically it
gives us the ability to have a wild-card
DNS entry and a single VIP on a load
balancer that all of our applications
can target that are running inside of
that infrastructure so you're provision
it once and it's good to go
DNS again wild-caught to the cluster
same thing like I just mentioned rather
than a manual provisioning process for
DNS there's a wildcard entry makes
things much easier to deal with much
more faster much easier to deploy
applications configuring service again
typically if you think of the life cycle
of a VM based application deployment you
request the VM you get some information
about that VM at some point in time an
IP address DNS name you then need to go
back to and second team and have them
configure a load balancer for you that's
typically not under your control as an
application developer in a large
enterprise that's something that a
separate team handles on the
infrastructure side this eliminates that
because you are now just using the
ingress controller that's built into the
kubernetes environment it's all handled
as part of your application deployment
very simple very straightforward having
a high availability control plane this
is an interesting one for us
we're in financial services a che is
very important to us getting a che for
every piece of your infrastructure that
supports your application deployments is
a challenge it's expensive
moving to kubernetes kind of solves that
a little bit and with gke on-premise
specifically we have the ability to have
highly available masters that are
separate from the actual user clusters
themselves this is great for us it gives
us the ability to scale that
independently provide high availability
there independently
the applications that are running they
to operations anneza touched on this a
little bit but this is a little bit more
specific to the actual application
deployments so patches and upgrades if
you think about VMware based deployments
how do you patch a VM you have to patch
a VM right well now you have a hundred
thousand VMs you have to patch a hundred
thousand VMs upgrades same thing you
want to do an OS upgrade that's a major
major challenge in a large enterprise
with GK on-premise kubernetes in general
you can do customer initiated auto
upgrades of the kubernetes environment
that have already been tested and
improved by Google it's not something
that you need to necessarily do
automatically right we're in enterprise
we wouldn't necessarily want something
to upgrade automatically behind the
scenes for us but it can be customer
initiated there's a button that you can
click to say I want to upgrade right now
I want to upgrade at this time works
very well for us reshaping
infrastructure I touched on this before
if you request the VM and a typical
enterprise it's a VM if you need that
changed if you need more memory more
CPUs allocated more disk space what do
you do you have to submit another
request it might be self-service but
there still probably an approval process
there and there's a timing thing well
with declarative intent we can put
people in a namespace that has certain
quotas associated with it they can
deploy what they want to their heart's
content in that namespace use their
resources and reshape their the
infrastructure that they're running
their application and up to their quota
and the quota itself can be a little bit
easier to an able self-service for works
very well again resizing services in a
typical deployment with VMs if you add
another VM to the service you have to
contact that load balancer team again
have them add the IP of the VM to the
load balancer to that application it's
not a seamless thing it's not quick to
do with auto scaling that happens
naturally built into two kubernetes
control plane visibility this is another
really interesting one for us if you
think about a typical infrastructure in
an enterprise many different components
many different vendors
getting all of that information in one
place typically relies on another tool
right you either need some kind of a sim
or a log aggregator to get all of that
information in one place to be able to
use and even then it's really never
perfect right with GK on Prem all of the
logs for the infrastructure that's
supporting all of the applications that
are running there are sent very nicely
into stackdriver over a tether works
very well troubleshooting and logging a
little bit more like control plane
visibility but this is more on the
application side in a typical enterprise
it can be very difficult to give
individual application owners access to
metrics related directly to their
applications in kubernetes and GK on
Prem we have really advanced tooling
with Prometheus and graph on ax it's
very simple to create custom dashboards
per application with our back wrapped
around them individual application teams
can see what they need to see to
understand how their applications are
behaving from a CPU and memory
perspective and network perspective and
we have stack driver for actual
application logs if that is what's
chosen to be utilized you know and as
mentioned that we've been working
closely on a lot of this stuff and we
have and I think that you know at the
end of the day all of the work that
we've done together has created a really
compelling package to have an enterprise
deployment at kubernetes that's really
scalable it works really well and we're
very happy with all the integrations
that have been done so far with that I'm
gonna hand it over to Sasha who's one of
the people that we've been working very
closely with and he's been great with us
working on all of the networking
components inside the product thank you
Paul and I have Scott joining me on
stage too so I'm gonna start out by
thanking Paul and Scott because they've
been working with us from get-go
quantifying a lot of these problems and
actually educating us a lot on what
actually works because when we started
GK on Prem be kind of recognized that
you understand unit
the best right it's not the cloud you
have your own constraints on who you
build the networks
you have your own constraints on what
works and why it is the way it is today
and our goal here was to go in and
actually attacked gke and kubernetes to
work best in your environment with
minimal overhead in terms of networking
cost but that was the way we thought
about the problem and and and hedges
busy has helped us a lot and actually
making that work and making that
actually doable in some sense and so
when we started out what we did was we
had to start with some principles right
and like how do we think about this
problem and we and we did it in terms of
these essentially five or six principles
so the first thing we wanted to do was
we wanted to support native kubernetes
constructs as much as possible so we
didn't want to go in and say oh because
you want to expose something as a web
service go do this other thing after you
deploy kubernetes service right we
wanted you to be able to use kubernetes
ingress right we didn't want to make
anything that was Google specific or GK
on-prem specific right we wanted support
kubernetes where it mattered that was
that was like the grounding principle on
which we we approach the whole problem
the second thing we did was we didn't
want to do yet another overlay like
there are enough overlays and in these
networking environments and we didn't
want to do it another overlay right as
much as possible but in order to be able
to support that and to be able to
support multiple applications without
having to expose IPS for everything we
decided to separate l4 from l7 load
balancing and ship l7 load balancing as
an inbuilt service within the cluster so
if you've used gke or used any cloud
think about it as you kind of assume HDB
load balancing happens for you bright
and and you assume there's a service
that doing that we wanted to give you
that same experience with GK on pram so
when you get want to get started out you
shouldn't have to think about how l7
will work it should just work right and
the last thing is having done the
separation we picked an envoy based
seven load balancer but then decided to
integrate with your existing elf for
solutions in your network so that you
don't have to kind of invent yet another
technology for how you want to do elf
all right so these were the grounding
principles of how we approach the
problem how we broke it down and and as
we we look at each of the details of how
we do control plane and data plane in
the following slides but those were the
principles and is you see through these
slides you'll see how they actually play
a role in how the solution evolves right
the very first thing as Dennis was
pointing out was how the control plane
itself tethers back to Google right so
if you think about it and this is one of
the very first insights that we had most
people just think on Prem and Google
cloud and they think it's two networks
but actually we we sat back and looked
at it's exactly three networks right
there is your on-prem network there is
your Google Cloud Network which is your
VPC and then there is the actual product
that Google's back services Ronna right
and then there there are three distinct
networks and you own in some sense your
on-prem network and your view of the
cloud VPC right it's your network
because it's new your project the other
stuff is Google hosted project Google
stuff right so when we wanted to tether
in we assumed that people have to
support multiple bonds from Catco like I
said we want to adapt to what you have
so there's two ways of the tether will
actually work it could dial out through
a [ __ ] proxy that you have in your
network assuming you're all close
networks and then do an SSL tunnel back
so you can get a secure end-to-end
connection on how your control plane
gets visibility on Pantheon and your
Google Cloud or you could actually go in
and if you have an inter connect connect
through the interconnect which will
route traffic through your BPC and stay
completely private to your enterprise
and never have to go to the public
Internet right so there's two modes that
you can use to actually go in and
register your clusters into the cloud so
you can do all the management of your
workloads or marketplace accesses and
things like that now what is it that is
registering it right so what is the
control plane itself looking like so one
of the things that we wanted to do is
why do we only tether a control plane
back and not run the control plane
remotely
we wanted you the ability to be able to
manage and run the control plane even if
you let's say loose internet
connectivity right this is your on-prem
Network as long as you're on print Metro
goes up you should be able to manage
your clusters and the way we did that is
by a separating the control plane from
the use of plane running a cluster just
for the control plane we call this the
admin cluster we host the workloads for
your masters use the clusters masters in
the admin cluster and then we let the
nodes that are there for the user
cluster run just the workloads which is
his own network if you actually step
back and think about it this exactly
what do you get in GK Google manages
your master on gke you get a bunch of
nodes which is a user cluster nodes that
you scale for your workloads you get the
exact same experience in G key on Prem
except that the admin cluster itself is
hosted locally it builds on the same
concepts and it exposes an l4 IP and the
user cluster nodes are completely for
user workloads and they just register
back to the master to do their
operations and we make all the wiring
board right and this then says
essentially what it does is you run zkct
all to create a cluster you you get
something in the admin cluster for your
manager and then you get all the work to
Lotus spun up and we go in and give you
a cube config file pointing to the
master API and you can just do cube say
DL apply at that point and your
workloads will then run on the user
cluster right so that's that's the
networking flow and and in order to
solve this we actually went in and had
to solve a bunch of problems and at this
point I'm gonna hand it over to Scott to
talk about it Scott actually interests a
lot of these decisions and why they were
valuable and talk about these choices
Thank You Satya
so as Anna said earlier we've been
working with them for about a year now
on this so when they first came to us
with the product
it was pretty a Google opinionated than
certain things that didn't fit with what
we need in the enterprise one of those
first things is that first bullet point
which is the static IP n so we also want
to use our our own load balancers
Stillen f5 it could be something else
but in order to use that the way
we have to use it internally we needed
static IPS those are in a pool so we can
still kind of leverage them I call it
dynamic static IP so we can still scale
out the clusters as needed so it went
from being DHCP base only into a option
so static which is populated through a
file so as not to of saying one of the
big advantages we have here when we
started our journey on kubernetes we
looked at every flavor you could
possibly think of if we were to do
multiple user control planes for say
business we would have multiple masters
all over the place in this case we have
our single up there all the user control
planes I think yes that's us Sam run
inside there in their own namespace and
that has your API server your sed
servers and they are all in an H a mode
that eliminates multiple VMs that we do
not have to create maintain patch get
IPS for so down there it's up to
currently I believe 10 that's what it's
gonna be sent you thanks God and that
kind of wraps up how we thought about
the control plane and essentially give
you the same flavor of GK ease
management on on Prem networks giving
the same separation of basically
administrator management being
independent of the user workload
management to be able to do each of
these independently right and I will
take a start taking a look at how the
data plane itself works so you've got
the cluster up you want to deploy a
workload on it how do we actually expect
it to work right before we go into how
the networking works this is kind of
like a context of the world view we were
we were trying to meet right you have
your on-prem cluster and you want to
deploy some micro services on it and you
want to expose it through some name and
clients in your network right this is
not like client's out in the Internet in
your on-prem network are trying to
access each of these internal services
and these services in some sense might
want to reach outside the cluster to
talk to say an existing data store and
existing back-end service that you want
to reuse and expose within the cluster
right as we looked at this picture there
were like three main requirements that
bubbled up the first is from a security
perspective and from just an IP
utilization perspective the ability for
power type is not being directly
reachable from the on-prem network came
out of something that's valuable right
so if you look at a company's cluster
you let's say what looking at a hundred
and ten parts per node so you want to be
a slash 24 but no do you want basically
eight to ten nodes you know start
looking at slash 20/80 and address
spaces and finding these contiguous
address spaces start becoming really
really hard when you have disjointed
outer spaces so by actually not having
part I was directly exposed you can
reuse these address spaces and not worry
about losing address spaces in your
on-prem environment actually bring up a
cluster right you're you just using an
IP for the l4 load balancer and IP for
the nodes and that's it so it looks
exactly like how you would deploy
iteration application except that for
that cost of a traditional application
you get a full kubernetes cluster right
so first drivers behind our networking
model this is starting networking model
which leads to a second point which is
essentially what I was talking about
limited number of IP is exposed and l4
load balancer we recommend doing a
wildcard DNS match so essentially you
want to be able to do name based routing
instead of IP based routing once your
traffic hits the cluster and finally as
Scott was also mentioning we gave the
ability to not just to DHCP but actually
a bag of static IP so you can give to
the cluster creation tool and say manage
my nodes IPS within this which lets you
then pre-configured a load balancer if
you want to use your own existing load
balancers use a shared service because
you know what the backends are you
basically telling the cluster use these
IDs for the nodes right so that's the
context behind how we thought about the
problem
Scott so I thought you were saying we
are as Paul is also mentioning when we
have a new service come in you've got to
get your IP address you've got to get
your DNS and something we didn't really
mention is certificates for that service
everything has to be encrypted so with
this model
yes that's you're saying we limit it to
like three IPs so we're going to need
off the bat it can be expanded but it's
me three of the Envoy based ingress
controllers so we use a wild-card DNS to
come in
and from there we also use a wildcard
certificate so our developers can spin
up anything that's gonna be in a layer
seven base and instantly have access to
it and they'll do this for a test site
as well so that I have you know site a
do their work site be different selector
on the ingress and they can test out an
application and cut things over in a
pseudo kind of a be deployment and in
the middle there what we talked about
the ingress it might be important to
mention associate we're not stuck with
just one it does support multiple
ingress is so I'm boy based shipping
with it but if you want to put nginx in
there as well you can do that for other
annotations that you might need or other
features for any other ingress
controllers thanks God and in order to
make that work what we had to do was how
do we make the part ip's in a way that
meets the kubernetes model which as
Ennis was pointing out assumes a flat IP
address space for partials in a cluster
which is if part a wants to talk to Part
B you assume they can directly reach
each other within the cluster but we
also said we don't want to expose part
IPS outside the cluster right just to
save an IP space so what we did is we
essentially build a node to node bgp
mesh which announces the slash 24 it's
allocated to each node for the pod IPS
so that they become basically they don't
you don't need an overlay to route the
pod I pasted right the underlying
network will actually route the pod I
pasted directly but since we never
announced the BGP routes outside the
cluster they essentially form what we
call an island of IPs within the cluster
but then this leads to the problem that
if a pod wants to talk to an external
database how was the traffic but what we
do is if you're part I P was reaching
outside the cluster but it's not
intended to another part IP you hit the
node boundary we basically mapped by the
nodes I peeing on egress and that way
the returned route will actually work
with connection tracking which
essentially then gives you an island of
a large IP space you can use slash 14 if
you want so you could just reuse between
each clusters because they never leaked
outside the cluster the only cost you
pay is the actual no type is themselves
which is function of the number of nodes
in a cluster
right so the first thing and now given
this cluster we look at how the traffic
flow works right the way the traffic
flow works says this Court was saying
you start with a wild-card DNS entry
that you mapped to an ingress service
right
we ship an aggressive is out of the box
if you go through a GK on-prem n stuff
it'll ask you what IP to associate for
the ingress service so you are actually
telling the system what IP to use but
you can then configure environment to
say here's a wild-card DNS entry that
maps to that ingress IP so let's say
start out a dot b dot scene to make a
little more concrete and a client wants
to reach a service s1 dot a dot b dot c
right so the wild-card DNS in your
environment are you configured once
we're basically pointed to the l4 load
balancer on which that whip was
configured the l4 load balancer will
then use standard kubernetes node port
backends to send that traffic down to
one of the nodes in a cluster
- it's not port at which point again
standard kubernetes takes over sense
that traffic down to the Envoy part that
we are running for the ingress service
which is essentially a subset of sto s--
pilot and on by combination this is four
knots of traffic and hits that part at
which point essentially all of this is
just control play firing envoy looks at
the l7 headers right it looks at the
hostname looks at the path you can
deploy a standard service with a cluster
IP so which is these are IPS in the
cluster that never go a reached out and
add a kubernetes ingress object that
says either a path based match or a
hostname which batch send it to our
service and the unwise then proxies it
down to your service so essentially what
this gives you is an ability to deploy
services with names within the wild-card
DNS name pattern without lowing Eddie
without losing any additional IPS for
each service are you put in and you
scale out the service scale and the
service within the cluster or let's say
a Scott was saying your service itself
could be nginx itself that you want to
do your own custom configuration all you
have to do is to say here's the hostname
match send it to my engine s nginx part
or service and all your configurations
will work and to N right so you can
essentially scale out your system by
having additional services command
and be able to route just by hostnames
within the cluster and your IP cost into
the network it's just that elf or Inglis
IP for 90% of your news cases right and
we also recognize there are other use
cases where you can directly use service
type load balancer but in most cases you
shouldn't have to if you're just doing
micro services Scott yeah an important
thing about when this gets set up
so those node ports you might be
thinking you have to statically assign
those over on the f5 to say ok if you're
looking for this you're gonna go down to
this pod over here in this node port
there's the f5 controller pod installed
by default that handles all this for use
so when it does get install the sake of
saying you basically just asked for a
couple questions a couple being like 20
but still and it just goes off and
deploys in about 30 to 35 minutes and at
that point your wildcard DNS will work
you got your pod running you know ports
running and as such you said you saving
all those addresses which is a big win
for us obviously at the scale that Paul
showed you that's a lot of IP addresses
and that doesn't count
what's over on our load balancer is
what's behind the scenes or what's just
internal to certain other clusters so
all this just helps our developers
basically do their CICE go from nothing
to a full app in 15-20 minutes whatever
they happen to have and everything is
running so this has been very well
received internally by our application
developers just on the installation that
we have installed for kubernetes in
general we had probably about 115 unique
namespaces within about two or three
months of use and the feedback we're
getting for people all of our developer
community has always been positive and
the speed but then if you realize you
actually sit down and think about it
routing inside the cluster we've assumed
is free right so said we've created a
mesh of all part IPS you've assumed all
part I visit regional all part I piece
which if your security person will start
kind of causing some point of worry
because how do I then protect because
you've said we want to have
multi-tenancy in some sense between
multiple services we won't host it
within the cluster they're all routing
through the unrep ID and how do we lock
it down and so recognizing that and
as its tablespace in most environments
we do ship natural policies
out-of-the-box right so any service any
service to service part about
communication you can lock it down based
on your intent right so you can say for
example in the previous slide you could
potentially say I have service s1 but
that's only reachable let's say from the
sto service for the on by part and not
by any other services in the cluster if
you want to do right or the backend for
service one is only reachable by service
one and so even if somebody wanted to
write an ingress rule that said expose
it as a new name metropoliz you really
want route the traffic down to that
service right so these are supported out
of the box it's kind yeah the network
policies have been a big request from
our developer community for alternate
solutions and pads environments or even
in full VM mode and it's very difficult
especially in fov mo to to let a
developer log in and say okay this
server can only go to a B or C so it's
been something and that we've needed for
a very long time and I know we have some
of our security people in this room
actually so I know this is something
that they're very happy about so it
gives a developer the ability to
configure this it's just standard
kubernetes network policies which many
of you have probably seen so you can
control your ingress and your egress
based on protocol ip's destinations so
this is something that we've been asked
by a lot of our businesses how am I
going to secure this and I did mention
on the previous slide that we have 120
130 namespaces
so obviously multi-tenant is one of our
concerns this is something that helps to
secure that multi-tenancy so we can have
only the applications talking to what
they should be talking to
so with that what we're gonna do I'm
gonna hand it back over to Anna's Paul
and myself will be available for any
kind of questions you have on the
enterprise portion of this and I think
Tatiana's will cancer some of the gke
base portions thank you Scott
as you see there's a lot of passion in
the team there's a lot of knowledge I
just want to wrap up with a couple of
thoughts first I want to thank you they
HSBC team for their partnership I truly
mean this we have been working on a
solution that truly fits their needs as
an enterprise and in doing so we have
insurance well that we provide the most
stringent highly available secure
solution that meets the enterprise needs
and we will not have been able to do
that without them it's been a you know
like relatively sure journey for what
these delivers we've been iterating
really fast
we have been leveraging of course a lot
on the technology knowledge expertise
that we have in-house and really
bringing all that goodness on Prem so
that this really gives you the solution
that really mimics the Google cloud geek
a solution that it's really kind of the
state of the art for a managed
kubernetes solution for enterprises
[Music]